difficile de se rendre de saint quentin
en yvelines à la défense ce mardi 13
septembre la ligne u est coupée dans les
deux sens de circulation depuis 4 heures
35 du matin
en cause une panne d'aiguillage au
niveau de porchefontaine ce
dysfonctionnement a aussi posé des
difficultés sur le rer c aucun train ne
peut circuler entre les gares de
viroflay rive gauche et saint quentin en
yvelines
les passagers doivent avoir recours à
des alternatives notamment la ligne n
entraînant certaines conséquences
j'ai plein d'amis du cou qui sont fait
avoir ils soirée vers avoir tort en quoi
je venais aujourd'hui la défense j'avais
que la lune était introduite dans gorge
et c'est la merde quoi donc je dirais
tourné à nassian pierre jadot très
timide à quoi je confirme que j'ai des
problèmes ce matin richard avait noté
une heure de retard et forcément mais
voit sont pas très comment un moment à
un peu marckois se demande s'il faut pas
acheter une voiture est arrêtée elle
était transports en commun pour se
rendre à la défense il est conseillé
d'emprunter le rer c puis le tramway à
partir d'issy les moulineaux
les agents de la sncf sont actuellement
sur le terrain pour réparer le système
le retour à la normale du trafic sur la
ligne e u devrait se faire ce mercredi
14 septembre